[Applaudissements]
c'est une salle conquise à eric zemmour
plusieurs générations de personnes
venues de versailles des yvelines et
plus globalement de région parisienne
tous sont venus écouter l'éditorialiste
une conférence organisée au palais des
congrès de la cité royale deux
personnalités politiques biennoises
étaient notamment présentes jean
frédéric poisson et laurence trochut
c'est des gens qui se sentent
suffisamment proche de moi pour venir
passer une soirée avec moi voilà après
vous en déduisez ce que vous voulez
moi je pense qu'effectivement ils n'ont
ces gens là n'ont rien à voir avec les
notables centriste de l air voilà quel
que soit le candidat par la partie n'est
pas exhaustive je suis d'accord avec lui
sur l'urgence des gens utilisation comme
je viens de dire nous partageons aussi
une même vision de la personne humaine
de sa place dans la société et je
partage avec lui cette inquiétude qui
est partagé je crois aussi par beaucoup
de nos concitoyens qui voit petit à
petit notre pays se déliter département
des yvelines va être une sorte de petit
laboratoire de l'élection présidentielle
parce qu'on voit d'un côté effectivement
que eric zemmour trouve ici de
potentiels électeurs si toutefois il est
il est candidat et puis de l'autre on
voit aussi que bon nombre d'élus qui a
encore un nom était membre des
républicains ont aujourd'hui rallié le
parti d'edouard philippe en soutien à la
majorité présidentielle en soutient
emmanuel macron pour 2022 et si on se
penche sur les scrutins précédents en
2017 les électeurs illinois avait placé
emmanuel macron en tête des suffrages au
premier et second tour les candidats en
marchant ont gagné 11 circonscriptions
sur 12 lors des législatives
depuis le parti des républicains a
regagné du terrain dans le département
lors des élections intermédiaires quid
alors de l'avenir du parti à l'échelle
nationale je sais que les élections sont
très bonnes pour pierre bédier je sais
qu'il est indéboulonnable pour l'instant
mais il incarne un système qui à l'ump
un conglomérat électoral plus exactement
qui aujourd'hui est très en difficulté
au plan national zemmour il essaie de
venir percuter ça donc je sais pas quel
impact savoir dans les yvelines mais ce
dont je suis certain c'est que
aujourd'hui il est une menace pour ce
genre de fiefs comme celui de pierre
bédier dans les habits noirs parce que
je crois fondamentalement c'est que les
yvelines
plutôt un territoire
d'électeurs du centre pragmatiques
opérationnelles ce qui en tout cas
départ n'est pas le profil des mots dans
les yvelines le rassemblement national
n'a jamais réellement percé marine le
pen avait obtenu 22% des voix au second
tour lors de la présidentielle de 2017
la question est réglée mot réussira-t-il
à bousculer les lignes politiques dans
le département si les candidats